sammarinese benvenuti in un nuovissimo
vi dirò prima di iniziare col video vi
ricordo che siamo vicinissimi a milioni
di iscritti e sono molto molto felice
non vedo l'ora
quindi mi raccomando se non l'avete
ancora fatto iscrivetevi al canale dopo
l'ultimo video che ho pubblicato
ne approfitto per ringraziare perché ho
ricevuto tantissimi messaggi stupendi se
non avete ancora visto che lo lascio qui
alcuni di voi mi hanno chiesto di fare
un video in cui insomma vi do dei
consigli sulle cose da fare durante
questo periodo in cui dobbiamo stare a
casa
ed eccoci qui ovviamente ho deciso di
ascoltare le vostre richieste quindi
ecco a voi un video sulle dieci cose da
fare a casa in questo periodo al numero
uno importantissimo anche per rimanere
in tema di igiene e di pulizia le
pulizie tanti di voi abiteranno con i
genitori quindi magari è la mamma o al
papà che si occupano appunto di questa
funzione tanti di voi sicuramente me
compresa
abitano da soli e quindi ahimé ceto
kabul
so che non è una delle cose più
divertenti del mondo e sono consapevole
però personalmente tutte le volte che
devo fare le pulizie mi infilo le mie
amate cuffiette e mi sparo a tutto
volume la mia musica preferita in
particolare adoro fare le pulizie come
sottofondo un po latina un po reggaeton
intuire con la musica in sottofondo è
molto più divertente in questi giorni da
tantissimo tempo libero mi sto
appassionando quindi e sanando a scovare
punti
molte nascoste che di solito non calcolo
assolutamente per esempio l'altro giorno
ha pulito il bagno detto ma quest'anno
si fonde andiamo può vedere tra ogni
fessura che cosa succede
non l'avessi mai fatto c'è tantissima
polvere
passiamo subito la seconda cosa da fare
a casa vi parliamo di uno dei miei
passatempi preferiti che mi segue ormai
lo sa io sono una fan di serie tv in
particolar modo quelle spagnole ma
questo è tutto un altro video ditemi se
anche voi non passate tutto l'anno
dicendo cavolo non riuscirò
vai a finire tutte queste serie non
riusciva mai a vedere tutti i film che
voglio vedere secondo me è arrivato il
momento adatto perché avendo così tanto
tempo libero da passare in casa potrete
sicuramente portarvi molto avanti e
vederne tante tante tante se vi posso
dare un consiglio fate di una lista
primi posti mettete le serie che volete
vedere di più e così via in modo tale da
organizzarvi da farvi un planning sulle
serie che volete riuscire a vedere ea
finire in questi giorni terza cosa che
vi consiglio di fare rullo di tamburi
sistemare so che tanti di voi stiamo
guardando gli avranno in che senso mari
si in quel senso sistemare la propria
camera avete capito tutti anch'io da
ragazzina non ero una super fan ma da
quando vivo da sola vi assicuro che è di
vitale importanza avere tutto sistemato
e ordinato oltre a sistemare la propria
camera quello che vi consiglio è di fare
anche un po di pulizia non pulizieri
senso di pulire perché ne abbiamo già
parlato ma polizia nel senso di provare
a eliminare qualcosa che magari non ci
serve più
io lo faccio spesso soprattutto con i
vestiti si è vestito la cosa in
questione è rovinata e rotta ovviamente
la butto se è ancora utilizzabile la
metto in un altro sacco che ovviamente
poi do ai bisognosi consiglio anche a
voi di seguire questo metodo quindi
separare in due sacchi le cose che
volete eliminare buttare e dare ai
bisognosi quarta cosa da fare leggere
legge un libro vecchia maniera quindi
sentendo l'odore delle pagine
sfogliandolo e immergendosi nella nella
storia che stiamo leggendo è una
sensazione un'emozione indescrivibile sa
se rari voi c'è qualcuno che non è
particolarmente interessato alla lettura
provateci vi consiglio di dare una
possibilità alla anche alla lettura e
vedere se riuscite a farvi catturare da
un libro quinta cosa da fare
all'esercizio fisico
anche qui ovviamente c'è chi magari è
super sportivo pratica degli sport a
livello agonistico chi si allena durante
tutto l'anno in palestra e quindi ama
allena
farsi e lo farà anche durante questo
periodo a casa che poi c'è chi magari un
po più pigro e nonostante durante tutto
l'anno voglia iscriversi in palestra
iniziare ad allenarsi non ha mai trovato
tempo voglia insomma troppe scuse e poco
impegno questo è il vostro momento da
casa potrete allenarvi benissimo facendo
degli esercizi molto semplici ci sono
tantissimi tutorial sul web
qua su youtube in particolare sul punto
workout da realizzare a casa magari
utilizzando appunto degli oggetti che
avete in casa del mio ragazzo adesso si
sta allenando da casa e usa le casse
dell'acqua per fare pesi quindi mi
raccomando se avete sempre avuto questo
desiderio e vi piacerebbe tornare in
forma o perdere qualche chilo tonificare
il vostro corpo
sfruttate questo periodo per mettervi in
gioco e provare ad allenarvi e
seriamente la stessa cosa da fare è
cucinare io come sapete durante l'anno
chi mi segue e magari su instagram avrà
visto che ogni tanto pubblico qualche
ricetta nei piace cucinare mi rilassa
molto in questi giorni e li sto non dico
specializzando però mi sto impegnando
molto sto sperimentando in particolare
io amo fare i dolci tre giorni avevamo
fatto una torta al cioccolato e per il
meraviglioso ma sono anche molto brava
con i primi risotti paste faccio anche
molto spesso le vellutate ogni volta
aggiungendo un ingrediente non so il
caprino alla fine con i semi che ha
insomma sto sperimenti brava mi faccio i
complimenti da sola scegliete la ricetta
che preferite il piatto che amate di più
e metteteli insieme alla vostra famiglia
al vostro ragazzo o alle persone sono
con cui vivete a cucinare divertitevi
scherzate e vedete ci tutto l'amore e la
passione che avete vi assicuro che
uscirà fuori un capolavoro settima cosa
che ahimè
non so se vi consiglio o dovete fare per
forza studiare so che per tutti coloro
che vanno a scuola o all'università è un
periodo un po difficile è nuovo mi
sembra che insomma stiate facendo delle
video lezioni se non sbaglio quindi
studiare
dovete studiare anche se non andate
fisicamente a scuola mi raccomando non
sottovalutate è la situazione nel senso
che state a casa ovviamente vi sembrerà
di essere sicuramente siete più
rilassati però mi raccomando studiate
soprattutto per chi all'esame quest'anno
impegnatevi usate questo tempo e magari
farvi già un'idea di tesina e per chi va
l'università ci sono passato anch'io
tanti esami magari arretrati che non
avete mai avuto voglia di affrontare è
arrivato il momento di farlo ottava cosa
da fare coltivare le proprie passioni
nel senso che se per esempio la vostra
passione è il canto cantate allenate di
ci sono tantissimi tutorial per
riscaldato il riscaldamento vocale
perché si di tutorial che vi insegnano
magari a correggere qualche
imperfezione che avete quando cantate se
invece la vostra passione per esempio
scrivere e vi piacerebbe scrivere un
libro avete tantissimo tempo a
disposizione per buttare giù le idee per
provare veramente a farlo oppure il make
up tante di voi mi chiedono maria come
fai toccarti così bene ci vuole pratica
ci vuole tempo ci vuole dedizione anche
per truccarsi se magari vi piacerebbe
imparare a truccarsi meglio seguite di
tutorial
allenatevi avete tutto il tempo che
volete a disposizione se sbagliate la
riga dell'eyeliner da potete imparare
finalmente a far la dritta pensa che
anche a cosa fare una volta finiti gli
studi finita l'università iniziati e
magari a creare il vostro curriculum che
vi servirà appunto per entrare nel mondo
del lavoro se ancora non l'avete fatto
insomma pensate al vostro futuro o
pensate le vostre passioni imparato cose
nuove e sfruttiamo al massimo questo
tempo per fare qualcosa che ci piace non
sa cosa da fare
prendersi cura di sé se non avete mai
fatto iniziati a prendervi cura di voi
stessi nel vostro corpo del vostro viso
se non avete una vostra skin che routine
è arrivato il momento di imparare a
utilizzare dei semplici prodotti per
migliorare l'aspetto della vostra pelle
non c'è bisogno di spendere tanti soldi
perché ci sono grazie dio infiniti
prodotti per la skin kerr con varie
fasce di prezzo quindi ognuno di noi può
utilizzarli quindi se non avete idea di
che prodotti utilizzare se non avete
ancora una skin che routine utilizza il
tempo avete a disposizione per
informarvi il web è pieno di di blog che
parlano di beauty quindi a seconda della
tipologia di pelle ci sono dei prodotti
da utilizzare prendervi cura di voi
stessi fa bene sia il nostro corpo alla
vostra pelle al vostro aspetto ma è
anche su per rilassanti io personalmente
quando mi faccio la mia pulizia al
mattino alla sera mi rilasso e mi sento
automaticamente meglio dopo provare per
credere
ultima cosa da fare ultimo mio consiglio
poi ovviamente le cose da fare sono
infinite e quello di riflettere un po in
che senso
durante l'anno
non abbiamo tantissimo tempo da dedicare
a questa sottovalutata attività e cioè
fermarsi staccare tutto non guardare il
telefono non pensare ai social non
pensare alle cose brutte ma focalizzarci
su le cose importanti quindi visto che
tutti noi insomma abbiamo delle persone
care lontane in questo momento perché
siamo obbligati a stare a casa
riflettere magari sull'importanza che
queste persone hanno per noi scrivere un
messaggio fare una chiamata dire ti
voglio bene tanti di voi mi hanno detto
che hanno relazione distanze cercate di
sfruttare la situazione in maniera
positiva coltivate come se fosse proprio
un fiore un giardino questo questa
vostra relazione facendo in modo che la
distanza tutta questa situazione che
stiamo vivendo faccia sì che il vostro
umore si è ancora più forte e posto
incontro alla fine di questo periodo sia
ancora più bello ed emozionante per
tutti coloro che hanno magari la
famiglia lontana in questo momento
sembra una stupidaggine ma steve è un
messaggio con scritto di pensili voglio
bene veramente un bel gesto e dovreste
farlo tutti perché è un periodo in cui
siamo tutti molto agitati tutti molto
preoccupati e quindi condividere
positività amore e affetto non può che
farci bene eccoci arrivati alla fine del
video
spero tantissimo che nei consigli vi
siano utili come sempre seguitemi sia su
instagram che su tik tok che sto
passando tantissimi contenuti anche gli
mando un bacione e ci vediamo al
prossimo figlio